the jurogan experience left the view by
the way
she left the view well she's free to be
on youtube we wish her well
imagine you as her on your show i would
love to interview her as her but i think
there's
there's such a small chance small
chance so you're saying there's a chance
that's gonna happen yes there is a
chance but it's not big
what if i helped her what if i was there
what if i was there like as a moderator
any
any you want to organize it i'll show up
i would do it i absolutely but you and
her together on this show well i think i
don't think i should do it the whole
time but i think it'd be fun to
interview her for five minutes and then
say hey megan
i get it i also hate joy behar so
i don't love you but i also hate that
squawking bird so
i hate the whole thing and frankly that
show you want to talk about a show that
set women back
is the view you want to talk about that
show if the cia is engineering
uh you know antifun [ __ ] the capital
riot
some crazy misogynist engineered the
view
because there's nothing worse than the
view in terms of like
there are so many brilliant women out
there none of them are on the view
none of them have gone near the set of
the view i mean they have brought in the
lowest tier
of of of of the what is it the y
chromosome
no wx double x they brought in the
lowest of the double x's for that one
it's rough yeah did you watch the
episode where tulsi gabbard got on to
defend herself and
joy behar starts panicking and going
over her notes while tulsi is refuting
everything that she said
yeah i mean joy bigger like again these
people have dementia
these are people who like should not be
allowed out of the house
they have a national platform i mean it
is crazy
they have no idea these people have
never read like a book and there's
versions of it
like than the other one with sharon
osbourne yeah
where what did sharon she said something
racially insensitive i think she said
that she doesn't like
i i don't i think she said why is pierce
morgan racist i don't even think it was
that bad she's friends with pierce
morgan right
yeah and she goes the thing that makes
you pause is cheryl underwood is cool as
[ __ ]
i know any of them but she's cool as
[ __ ] yeah i know
her forever i've i did montreal comedy
festival with her back in the day
she's [ __ ] hilarious you're seeing
her stand up i know that she's great
because i know people that know her but
i never
she murders yeah she goes on stage with
her purse yeah yeah she's fine really
funny
yeah really funny and cool as [ __ ] so if
she doesn't like her i gotta go
man you know what i mean yeah there's
probably something there
there's probably something there i don't
know but i remember when she was making
fun of the guy who got his dick chopped
off
and the wife threw it in the blender
right or he threw it in the garbage
disposal and she was laughing about what
it must have looked like
his little wee rolling around inside no
one wants
that she's not anybody's but that's a
crazy thing to laugh at
a guy getting his dick chopped off and
someone throw
like he's getting mutilated yeah his
humanity is taken from him
manhood is literally getting grounded
yeah and she thought it was funny
but again people think things are funny
because they don't think
about the person they're making fun of
you and i are both guilty of that of
course
as comics absolutely but that one was
like particularly
like wow rough well just it was started
to view and then they have all these
ones they're like the talk
yeah you know and it's just like and
then everyone gets like
c-list and then d-list and then they're
like resurrecting sitcom stars from the
80s
yeah like what do you think about
palestine it's like what are we doing
here right
we don't need any of these people's
opinions yeah it's
it's a [ __ ] weird thing man like uh
sherry shepherd she used to be on the
the view as well she's really nice too
she was at the store
she's always cool as [ __ ] i'm sure
they're all nice she was really nice
sherry shepherd is a really nice lady
and she's also like
super religious like she's a god-fearing
christian woman
like full stop you know yeah i just i
can i suggested think for the view this
is a suggestion i have
men no chance just men
on the show but women watch it see
that's the thing it's like
it's a lot of it is women that are home
right during that time it airs during
what if we put the women in the audience
and that the men discuss the issues this
is just an idea i have for abc
corporate well clearly or have one woman
serve everyone drinks and give her a
quick opinion
quick in and out just go live the guys
go just go
she go she walks in she goes yeah israel
seems like it's a go thanks
and then they keep going i think that's
a happy medium why doesn't the view have
any trans women on it
great point it has a lot of women that
look trans but none of them
it has a lot of second and third takes
after a drink you'd go huh
but it doesn't have a ton of yeah it's
zero i agree
it should be all trans women imagine the
best era of the view and i've talked
about it before was when rosie o'donnell
was talking about building seven yeah
that was the bed that i watched
that was okay catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience